Life. We truly appreciate your
father's work here in Texas.
Would you ever consider
a career in politics?
Okay,
well, I appreciate that. Uh, there's a,
just a Sarah by understands that my
dad is, uh, a US congressman now. Uh,
he's a freshman, you as
congressman from a Texas district,
36 and southeast Texas. And
uh, I'm very proud of him.
He retired after a career as a, as
a small town dentist, uh, you know,
business, a selling point, business
for army and the air force, army,
army and air force veteran. And uh,
he was fed up with Washington and
didn't like the options that he saw. Uh,
you know, that he knew were going to
be running for that seat. And he said,
you know what, I'm throwing my hat in
the ring. I'm going to go up there.
I'm trying to make a difference. And I,
we need more people like
that in Washington. Dad Is,
my dad is there to make a
difference and only to make it deal.
He doesn't care about a career.
He didn't care about being there for
decades and decades and decades. You know,
he's a, he's retired and
he'd rather be fishing,
hanging out with his grandkids and,
and hunting. But, uh, he would,
but he's up there.
He cares about the country and he is
sacrificing to be there and to lead.
And I'm, I'm damn proud of
the job that he's doing. Uh,
and stepping up what I consider
a career in politics. Uh,
I can't imagine anything to be more
miserable than that. Uh, you know what,
on the other hand, when I look at our
nation, just as my dad know, has, uh,
uh, as has felt, you know, called to
do that, to step up, to lead, you know,
if we don't do it, who's going to do it?
So somebody has got to step up
if somebody has got to lead.
And I think when you look at the direction
of our country right now in the, the,
the political climate and, and
all that's going on, you know,
in this electoral cycle, um,
what I do that maybe I just might
be able to be talked into it. Uh,
we shall see what about UJ go get some,
I mean we got, we got the
bumper stickers Jocko 2016,
uh, you know, see that go Charles.
I think I would be running as if
I was to run for political office.
I would run as a dictator
and it's supreme ruler of,
of America. And that's why I
thought I would do, we, we can,
we can bring back some of the Roman
rule, try and triumvirate. So me,
you and echo who could
just take, take over a,
I don't know if I have
the stomach for politics.
I really don't like the political arena
too much and not sure it's something I
would ever, ever have the
desire to do. You know,
I guess that's my, that's where I sit.
Maybe when I was 70 years old.
Um,
yeah, people, people have asked
me to, you know, like, Hey,
if you were president, what
would you do? You know,
about the situation
with the Ron, you know,
and their development of nuclear
weapons or China getting, you know,
making big moves in the south China Sea
or Russia pushing the envelope. And, uh,
and, and kind of throwing
their noses at us.
And often I've told them
that if I were president,
I would immediately nominate Jocko
Willink, his secretary of defense.
We would change secretary of defense to
the previous title of secretary of war.
And, uh, and I think those problems
would, would disappear immediately. Um,
I think if I was president,
it'd be very smooth.
My policy would be pretty
simple. My policy would be
kick ass. That's what we would
do. Economics. We can do,
what's your economic plan? Jocko?
Kick ass. Well, what's your,
what would you do with this situation
over here in the Middle East? Oh, there.
Oh yeah. Well we're gonna do
theirs. We're gonna kick ass.
What about the drug problem that we've
got coming in through the borders? Oh,
the, the drug cartel. Yeah. We're
going to kick ass on that. So that,
that's my policy. So this is why I
probably wouldn't be the best politician
that Kinda like BTF the same thing. Yeah.